[Music]
reading lots of reading like Blade
Runner levels of reading well I love the
escape capsule when you secure the
samples which means you'll definitely be
dead after the first scene they really
missed a chance to cast Drew Barrymore
in this role I liked had they hired a
person to write this movie about giant
animals destroying cities and that
person's first thought was space
obviously wow I didn't think anyone
would be able to challenge the quality
of the CGI and Geo storm but you proved
me wrong movie that escape pod is
travelling in an extremely specific
straight and convenient line for her to
be able to witness the station's
destruction through this tiny ass window
with basically Steadicam view to Mun g3
welcome to the rampage Oh pink connor
and so begins what is roughly 936
progressively louder roars of dominance
can someone to a supercut of these
replaced by me sighing during the CID
narration the thought of that happening
almost makes watching this movie
bearable it's not gonna kill you he has
a unique sense of humor I know this has
played for laughs but the lack of
information about George could seriously
have killed Connor I know he's a dill
weed and all but you don't have to play
with his fucking life he's in your troop
now I want you to welcome it but not
badly enough to wait until you can turn
around and can see me signing this
information movie has time for this
starting using this new vegan deodorant
how's that like guacamole
ladies and gentlemen written by three
screenwriters and Carlton Cuse is he
driving it's like an SUV got
monochromatic and then added tractor
wheels I can't even tell what this is
overcompensating for Jesus Christ do you
mean that even though that tiny-ass
escape pod exploded they made these
canisters to be impervious to re-entry
pickle a movie either you're gonna try
and make a somewhat believable origin
story for the rampage and later on or
you're just gonna blow toxic smoke up
our asses huh these canisters seem to be
actively selecting wildlife
preservations for their landing spots
George clearly attended the Alien
franchise school of touching alien
things is this seriously all the
Divine's of the gorillas from the
grizzly bears like couldn't either
species figure out how to lift an easily
movable lever to open the door how does
this confrontation not happen before
even by accident
is he gonna shoot the giant white ape
through the rock I know you thought you
blocked this well enough so it would
look like he was pointing the gun at the
ape and not the rock but you did not
block this well enough go back and do it
again you'd better come take a look at
this cliche we're doing the morning
rounds and on this their morning rounds
these assholes were completely green
yesterday and are working in an
extremely unstable environment for
anyone other than Davis but they're
allowed to check the grounds by
themselves now awesome someone thought
to use protection while picking up a
foreign possibly alien container of a
possibly hazardous substance sure nobody
has on even the most rudimentary safety
equipment but hey at least he's using a
plastic bag what is it
it's a tesseract I mean an Allspark I
mean I'm only err I don't know gotta
figure it out do you like do you gotta
figure it out why not the authorities or
scientists you immediately tell about
this and hand this over to why can't
they got to figure it out somebody finds
that sample it leads straight back to us
jason sudeikis his little brother would
be excellent at cinema since putting the
actual rampage arcade game in your
Rampage movie based on that game even if
it's only a quick Easter Egg breaks the
fabric of your movie space-time
continuum all to help there's no reason
we were doing these experiments in space
and it was exactly for the betterment of
humanity this implies you were doing
them in space because they are illegal
and that's an incredibly stupid reason
to spend tens of billions of dollars on
a space station
he's such a badass he literally drives
with an unholstered handgun in his right
hand
I mean why do you even need to put scars
on his arm and hand at that point scars
Mars he was driving with a gun in his
hand when the scene opened we learned
they are in Colorado in Colorado is very
similar to Wyoming in terms of terrain
it's literally right above Colorado so
close that I find it hard to believe
dufus here has never been to Wyoming but
even if he hasn't living in Colorado
this close to Wyoming should mean it
doesn't need to be told what Wyoming is
like so you just wanted some banter that
sounded clever and let one of these
meatheads call another one of the
meatheads an animal and have everyone
laugh while the chopper takes off like
this is exactly the kind of thing we
started making these videos about
because it's lazy and it gives the
appearance of being a screenplay
when it's really just bad junior high
writing I don't know what this person is
studying I mean damn this lady's got
genetics books lying literally all over
her apartment dramatic video of a
fireball it is thought to be debris from
last night's athena one tragedy it's
unclear if this is related to one of the
parks guerrillas escaping the enclosure
at the sanctuary earlier this morning
there's a lot of exposition crammed into
a local news broadcast that would
definitely be more focused on the giant
space station explosions that is not
great so can we get to some goddamn
rampaging already I mean this oh please
tell me you have that tested for
residual particulates yeah right lady we
do science a little differently around
these parts demonstrating levels of
aggression you don't see in his species
but that whole first scene in the
wildlife sanctuary was all about the
gorilla aggression right but grizzly
bear the most powerful terrestrial
predator on the planet how do you
determine the most powerful terrestrial
predator is it jaw strength how long it
can go without eating kick strength how
much it can benchpress
I don't doubt a grizzly is a bad mother
but in defense of the Lions Silverbacks
Crocs boa constrictors and hippos of the
world we need to set some firm criteria
before just summarily defining the
grizzly as the most powerful predator
you familiar with CRISPR yeah genetic
engineering it's more like genetic
editing check this out extremely
intelligent geneticist immediately turns
to Wikipedia to tell Davis about genetic
editing because it's got pictures of
sharks
along with increased size speed and
agility the CRISPR edits also turn you
into a jump scaring dick see in a better
movie I might remove ass in here for
causing a good laugh but the problem
here is science fiction that is trying
to be grounded in the real world this
isn't The Simpsons so now I have to
assume that has literally happened
before and that makes me angry I like
this movie the first time I saw it when
it was called rise of the mighty Joe
skyscraper hurry what do you think if
the deer were spooked then why the are
they running to the giant wolf and not
away from it I know the wolf's been
super juice for power and speed and all
that bull but is there something in that
gas that makes a giant monster
completely silent until they're ready to
pounce Tom Cruise would have landed it I
bet brother I'm gonna prance myself
right out on the limb and guess what no
one's ever accused you of being a people
person I bet you take these cuffs off
and you find out yourself
booby slips in some rejected Hobbs and
Shawn dialog because hey free dialog
Army Special Forces what are you some
kind of international man of mystery
exposition timid Asian also oh I love
how they have to keep making up military
and/or professional sports backgrounds
for all the characters The Rock plays
because he's just too damn Jack to play
a normal dude that sedative is gonna
become an effective long before we're
back on the ground but Keith doesn't
know where they're going damn I wish I
had a sedative to knock me out for the
rest of the movie weirdos on the
Internet cone him Ralph what even is
this movie weirdos on the internet or
calling him Ralph did 13 what I'm sure
were glorious months in our beautiful
Greenville Federal Correctional
Institute I am guessing by the look on
the big fellas face but this is all news
to him who cares sure Kate told Hobbs
that she worked at energyne but she
never specified went and even though
they don't know if there's an antidote
for sure she's the best one to create it
also I'm gonna add ten sins for Jeffrey
Dean Morgan spur Foreman sear he's
obviously trying to ham it up as the
cowboy government spook with a morally
ambiguous backstory but it's so goddamn
obvious that it's free greeting lucky
for us this building has some of the
most powerful radio antennas in the
I had our team modify this one last
night so not only are they using the
Sears Tower as a transmitter to call the
Monstars out they were able to get that
done in one night so let's talk about
the evil lady's plan
she was engineering genetically modified
super creatures in space but just in
case that station exploded and the serum
somehow made it back to earth and came
in direct contact with animals that then
became super animals they pre-programmed
the serum to create a reaction in the
eventual possible super animals so that
a low-frequency radio signal would draw
them to it like the Pied Pipers flew and
now she's gonna broadcast that signal
from the top of the Sears Tower Goff
Willis stands to draw the super animals
to the top of the Sears Tower do I have
that right I mean yeah giant rampaging
eight but should you really fire a
machine gun on an airplane but also how
the many machine gun bullets can this
four take before he goes down yes they
modified his DNA and something-something
regeneration but he's still a god Annie
right he's taking at least 50 bullets in
the last minute he should be dead man it
sure is good they have the one
primatologist that also just happens to
be a retired Special Forces badass
imagine if they've taken this trip with
light colored pink Connor last night I
had a dream that Darth Vader came down
from the planet Vulcan and told me if I
tried to explain the last two minutes of
this movie to you it would melt my brain
George survives this how the hell did
the other two catch up with Kate she
jumped a full minute before they did and
the plane was still dropping straight
down so either she should be much higher
or much lower than that he's wounded but
he survived a plane crash okay at this
point we can just assume George is a
combination of King Kong the honk and a
cast member of The Fast and Furious
franchise I my grandpappy always said
those assholes gotta stick together
internal cinema since corporate
motivational mantra ends up in a movie
script see that was quite the fireball
why is it more of this corn on fire
right now despite people so much me tell
you something I've fought in wars all
over the world ah exactly what I needed
in my arcade game adaptation about large
animals smashing buildings on abundance
of backstory but also the flashback of
the rock working as a un-backed stealth
animal conservation ninja killing
poachers and discovering baby George
would have been a much better movie than
this one
good thing George doesn't feel the same
way about people skip it sounds like a
plan
whew glad we wrapped up this
conversation right before the plot
convenience chopper showed up the
bastards are never late these two know
more about these creatures than anyone
on this planet do they though the rock
only knows George and it's already been
said many times that he's morphed enough
that he's not the same anymore
and Kate tried to destroy the weaponized
DNA serum and hasn't been with the
company since and that was a couple
years ago and I'd argue plenty of people
at the company know more than her
Colonel you have to evacuate Chicago he
says this with the earnestness of
someone that actually thinks it's
possible to do that a few minutes time
this operation is gonna go south fast we
have to get to Chicago you're gonna do
that no one else can do is he gonna talk
George down at this point are you going
to instantly find the cure after
breaking into energyne headquarters oh
never mind that's exactly what's gonna
happen isn't it let's not do this thing
I'm gonna have to knock you out and then
you look at me I'm gonna choke you out
so bad you're gonna urinate yourself you
see the rock can be intimidating
charming charismatic and funny when he's
given good material so stop giving him
this rampage baywatch furious bulls and
let him be him I'm so pissed about this
that rather than removing a cinema add
five more they probably have a grounded
medevac chopper at the hospital that's
why you always bring a doctor what do
you mean someone didn't see San Andreas
copy that
wait Harry toss them a cell phone and
said I'll be in touch they got on the
helicopter and minutes later he calls
from a cell phone to the choppers radio
does the military medical chopper have
an iPhone dock that syncs with the
vehicles radio and if it somehow does
which it does not why would he know
about it or how to use it this might be
the wonky as' thing in this movie and
that's saying something they're never
gonna get everyone out of the city in
time I can't even believe they got this
many military vehicles into the city
this fast why the hell are they flying
in from the north side of the city they
were coming in from due south of the
city and we're told monster if we're
making a direct beeline for the tower
did they want a quick flyover tour
Wrigley Field before they joined the
fight
this might be the stupidest movie I have
ever seen
where is one off one it bouncer awesome
but what about warthogs two through
fifty
he didn't just send one complaint in
there did you where are we with the
evacuation
50% downtown sir you here comes the
giant croc no one but the audience knows
about imagine if they hadn't spoiled him
with heavy foreshadowing this could have
actually been a cool moment it's
important to stretch after a long trip
well that sucks
movie surprisingly includes footage of
the Rock's initial reaction to the first
cut of this movie
I thought they were being drawn to the
signal and would stop at nothing until
they stopped the signal why are they
wasting so much time rampaging right now
other than the title of the movie well
hmm can't argue with that
they can't stop them we got to get that
okay first of all you knew this already
that's why you stole the helicopter and
came here so I don't know why you spent
so much time watching this rampaging and
then felt the need to restate the reason
you're here I still don't know why you
went straight from sending one warthog
to drop the near nukes and skipped right
over this send a bunch of warthogs at
once because when that thing first
opened fire on the ape and the wolf look
like them's hurt because the animals ran
for cover instantly I'm just saying I
thought oh no who would ever have
expected the super-secret lab to have a
locking mechanism curse of technology
everything in the lab is on one system
the FBI would never have thought to
confiscate a thermostat um yeah they
would they'd be able to detect Network
connected devices and they saw season
four Silicon Valley there's a backdoor
another server there's a backdoor into
the server well one single shot to the
right abdomen not definitely killed him
so nothing else to do here
here took him long enough
god this is so dumb
why did Claire wait this long to leave
knowing the Sears Tower is exactly where
the monsters are coming and every news
crew in the world is covering this and
the antidote was sitting in the lab the
whole time feeding a monster what the
straight-up murder also how do you know
the antidote canister will open inside
her bag inside the ape how do you even
know he's gonna eat her since the last
human he screamed at he threw off the
building also also with Malin Akerman
character gone I guess all those
Watchmen fans will have to wait a little
longer for the on screen Silk Spectre to
comedian reunion you know these monsters
have had no issue taking down entire
buildings and wrecking all kinds of why
the hell's it taking so long for them to
break off the antenna of the tower
Suicide Squad said no movie has ever
demonstrated more luck in surviving
chopper crashes than our movie and
rampage said hold my beer holy I forgot
all about this fin bomber
how far away did that thing launch from
England well it was always going to end
with George saving the day of course now
that he's fighting the other two it's
just another giant ape movie oh Jesus in
Christ on a Saltine
I really hope they include this scene
when the Academy eventually gives Dwayne
Johnson a Lifetime Achievement Award
things rocks projectiles monsters
excitement also remember when he got
shot the torso and was super Limpy and
wheezy yeah and neither does the movie
and this alligator asshole really must
want to savor his rock candy
[Music]
why is this movie making like he's gonna
die from this he regenerates goes did
you read you own George somehow
understands this even though we've long
since abandoned the use of sign language
during this fight oh yeah just a random
perfectly functional a fully loaded
military chopper sitting with an easy
running distance pointed right at my
target you mess with my friend you mess
with me mother can pg-13 movies please
stop doing this I'm begging you Jesus
Christ this is like the fourth ex
machina the last five minutes alone
again the movie is playing at the idea
that George might die it's offensive
really read your own fucking script he
regenerates George finally reveals what
the movie has been giving us for the
last 98 minutes well I can tell you
right now we're not gonna put him on a
plane ha ha ha the entire loop area
Chicago along with countless lives have
been gruesomely destroyed over the last
half hour ha ha ha this is a dumb movie
that's really bad honestly still liked
it better than school island
this is my sandbox I'm not allowed to go
in the deep end he might be okay
no probably No
got a dog new Newark you're crazy
I like you you should I have a bad
feeling about this mission please
elaborate that's the same feeling I had
about Mardi Gras 1987 our team is the
elite of the elite with the heart soul
of this very Beach my family is the only
thing that matters to me right now
[Music]
George George George George of the
jungle stone yes he can't be